three to welcome one and all to the h3
podcast i'm your host ethan klein and
with me my beautiful co-host wife best
friend and mom extraordinaire not my mom
but our child's mom a klein looking
sharp and beautiful as ever
today's episode is sponsored by stitch
fix stamps calm and hems
now guys this is probably one of the
best episodes we have ever made so we're
not gonna want to miss out not for a
single second because we have surprises
throughout this episode so if you skip
ahead you may miss those surprises now
let's start from the top I mean we've
got an attenuation of scooter madness
you guys know that I've been fascinated
with scooters I can't get enough and
they keep coming in fascinating so we're
gonna be getting to scooter madness as
well as shopping for our ultimate
scooter and buying it I think we've got
big plans for becoming scooter people
ourselves as we as we hold them in such
high regard no it's usually a disability
mobility what wouldn't your disability
be that I'm fat which is like 90% of all
the people who ride scooters to be
honest like that I've got a bunch of
videos here they eat [ __ ] on the scooter
and then they just get up yeah it's like
dude you're just fat like maybe if you
walked around you want to need the
scooter sorry I don't know if that makes
me a fat person hater but if you crashed
your scooter and you stand up and walk
away from the crash scene maybe you
don't need the scooter and are they fat
every time yes exactly
so in short that's my disability I'm
Tobie's but before we get into that I
want to show you a product that's really
popping off on Twitter why why can't buy
a river when you can camp on one which
is a interesting question too close
and I think and I think I can answer it
did you lower this yeah I can come music
just in case I'm nice
here I'll just cut it yeah so this is a
tent that allows you to sleep on the
water
aka a watery tomb this here is where you
are guaranteed to die
just imagine okay this is the dumbest
thing ever okay you first of all if it
gets punctured do you understand that it
will deflate in the water and you will
be encapsulated in it okay you'll be you
will be your base do you know what
you're doing you know the mob kills
people and like puts them in bags and
throws in a river this is basically a
convenient way of dumping your own body
in the river do you know what I'm saying
I feel like it's something that like
sounds really awesome but then look at
this idiot you exactly how pathetic it
is I mean you look like that look at
this idiot trying to make it look like
convenient so also there's no anchor
it's look at this there's no anchor
you're just gonna float downriver
aimlessly you're gonna hit the bank
you're gonna immediately crash into the
bank so you might as well be on land
you're gonna go wander off into some
Rapids probably takes like 5 hours to
put this thing together it's gonna be
dark when it comes with so it doesn't
come with an anchor and it comes with a
foot pump to blow this thing up and it
costs $2,000 no I would pump my hand
do you understand I do just to put in
perspective when we did the beach ball
video right we had an electric pump and
we stood on the side of the road for
probably over an hour yeah a foot pump
dude I used a hand pump you know our
flame thrown that's an hour by hand and
that this would take you 20 out more no
I noticed this clip going viral lately
on Twitter for some reason
but I have watched every episode of the
Prophet yeah we love that any prophet
fan out there would recognize this was
on the show yeah and my favorite part
about it is that it didn't listen to
Marcus Marcus suggested that he changes
the name of the companies right now it
says Smith fly because he started with
like products for fly fishing right
so Smith fly but it doesn't make fishing
stuff it's just camping stuff now yeah
so you said the whole episode was like
you got to change the name right and he
never changed it but to be frank I don't
think the name is the problem here she
not I mean like and just you know maybe
in defense against Marcus I don't think
dropping fly is gonna make them
successful out of the name well we'll
never know because he never tried it
that's a good point
um what could possibly go wrong we've
got a bunch of literature here
let's see but in the end this is so good
here watch this scene from the Prophet
so they're picking it to like outdoors
world or something yeah and so these
guys are like start asking basic ask
questions like you know it's a point of
failure that like we might be
introducing does it come with any type
of anchors it does not come with an
anchor no anchors are pretty specific to
what water type you're on it's a weight
anchors are specific to what type of
water you on what are they going in the
ocean you don't you know what I mean if
you use that anywhere else on a lathe
and ocean if you go on a lake with this
how the [ __ ] are you gonna have an
anchor you'd have to have like a
200-foot anchor it's River only dude you
cheap [ __ ] how do you put a cool
upholders in it it has speakers yes or
no no we got a hundred million views of
it right it's a unique product it's a
tough sell I love when they say that we
have a hundred million views it's like
all right well clearly nobody bought it
and now that that viral sensation has
passed and you're not successful what do
you want me to do well Marcus invested
he bought half the company for a million
billion dollars for 50% that's a bad
investment Marcus no the thing was that
the guy who was actually you it was
really good at creating this product he
has like boats that he makes and they
look amazing so if you listen to Marcus
it could have turned it into a
successful business if you would have
just dropped the fly you got to drop the
flag Smith why look at Marcus he's like
did I waste my money there like problems
talking about an anchor man that's such
a bad product should we buy it for dumb
products mm just drown well bye guys it
would be funny to take it out to like a
river puncture it and then watch as we
die like even with like first aid at the
side it would collapse around you do you
underst suction sealed no it's fantastic
so good luck to Marcus on his 1 million
dollar investment who by the way ghosted
us on Twitter Marcus was supposed to
come on and he goes to me but he's a
busy man he's a very serious man in fact
kind of shy pull up his Twitter profile
no I have no pride like Marcus why am I
talking like talking [ __ ] right ela what
am i doing that's right come on Ethan
have some [ __ ] class you're speaking
of the guy indiana's he was considered
coming on
now you're trying to air the dirty
laundry start beef with Marcus right
there is no dirty laundry there's beef
with me and Marcus house yo okay this is
kind of a old clip but I feel like I
just now understood
oh no it's from this year I just now
understood how amazing this clip is so a
pass an officer passed away in the line
of duty duty not funny in the slightest
bit no no no so here's her name like
Deidre men in doubt or something
Deidre men a'dope okay and you know
residence two men stole something so
anyway rest in peace to her you know
fallen all in the line of duty we salute
her we think her first service but this
reporter got her name wrong let's hear
it the only recording exists I was like
can can't we find the live of this the
only thing that exists is just this one
hero who filmed it on his [ __ ] phone
the original source doesn't exist one
dude just rewinded captured it i
preserved this moment for all humanity
I love mega dude who is such an epic
name oh I gotta start calling my mega
Doo doos see when I first saw this I
thought it was trolling but she actually
just Oh Luke
we should clip this CD mega dude
[Music]
dan you catch at the very end there
she's she immediately is apologizing it
cuts off unfortunately but she's like
I'm sorry oh yeah
I wonder if somebody [ __ ] her on the
teleprompter like burgundy style you
know what I mean cuz I don't see how you
can print from that do yo any time
someone missed speaks from now on I want
to clip that soundbite and play DD mega
doodoo anytime someone miss speaks so
make sure that gets to that that's an
important sound buy it
Roger that I don't know what to say I
mean I'm trying to get comfortable over
here and sometimes I got a lean back
okay stop bringing a claim
I sell we got under five seconds if you
say the lean back three times you get
clamped mice you're in the clear all
right well rest in peace - DD mega doo
doo let's move it on to the scooter
madness we of course have received
numerous submissions of submissions
continue to come and I would love to see
more in the Trevor treasure trove mm-hmm
podcast a trace reproductions comm
scooter madness is a Trevor Trevor if
now it was Zach I would play DD mega due
to right cuz I got my you know words
mixed up mmm telling you guys are not
ready for today's scooter segment and
what keep doing these until we've
watched every scooter segment there is
until you guys are gonna absolutely love
this
come on it doesn't get better
grandma honest and I don't know what's
going to work without knowing what's
gonna happen it's already funny yeah you
got some old lady on a scooter holding
onto a rope
now why did this grandma is by herself
in a mall there's nobody in this mall
she's the only inhabitant of this giant
space is this grandma on a scooter how
does that even happen it's inexplicable
but what happens next will shock and awe
and surprise and shake you to your very
core dee dee mega doodoo I love that the
dude who's recording this from the
security camera is just silent you can't
hear him laugh or breathe or even snort
alike like breathe have his nose from
laughs he's like just silently what
imagine his face is just totally
straight hmm what's happening is
grandma's holding onto a rope and she
clears her head she's going under it on
a mobility scooter clear their head but
Nana doesn't cook doesn't realize that
it catches on the headrest and so she
does a complete flip-flop and she eats
[ __ ] hard baby in the bag it's a mess
and not hard though it always seems like
well fine she's got the headrest the
thing is that there's nobody in that
mall so she's gonna be there till the
morning I didn't know where's everybody
it's just her and this one guy watching
the security camera with this perfect
fairy fence I just imagine he's like
this which is kind of psycho
yeah that's a good one I always love
when the bag falls out it's like such a
compounding tragedy but do you rate that
one
scooter fail oh I'd say beginner fail
not a high level the fact that it's an
Anna kind of makes it less fun too cuz
you're like well it's an old lady but
it's funny i watch any scooter fail I
don't give a [ __ ] I have one where
people actually break their hips coming
up like literally they break their
[ __ ] hip and it's hilarious I'm sorry
to say that but what am I supposed to do
you know people go there was just one
clip where the guy on the wheelchair
like literally suicides he dies that's
the one we're describing on the elevator
and I'm like look it's still hilarious I
didn't see his body splat on that you
know what I mean I didn't see the
violent conclusion that's not funny
but watching his little scooter
disappear under the elevator door after
trying three times is [ __ ] hilarious
and the fact that he died is kind of you
know another story I see right yeah
you're talking about those oh it's funny
you know stop laughing oh he died it's
like well it's still funny is this a
this is where I'm this is where I'm
dying this is the hey this one's funny
this is a good well you tell me you rate
this one this good of people in such a
hurry that like an airport they don't
know they don't learn the controls they
don't know what they're do you say it's
still going they don't know what they're
doing and they can [ __ ] walk
so this woman's at an airport she's in
so much of a hurry the sliding glass
door open she doesn't slow down she
comes she comes slamming through the
glass shatters everywhere and then what
happens she gets up immediately and
walks and the scooter keeps moving let's
watch this I think once we buy a scooter
and use one it will help us understand
so much more it's so complicated about a
scooter it's made for people with semi
functional
there's only like one function they need
to exactly
there's go and stop I mean it's not more
complicated than that here we go she's
just like she cannot fine
oh and then on the flower window it says
dude the huazi wipeout I guess she did
the huazi wipeout it's like an ad or
something she just [ __ ] destroyed
that glass door and she's gonna peace
out to that well I want his [ __ ]
scooter so eat [ __ ] she can walk look at
her she's pushed she can walk there's no
issue with her walking she's not that
overweight even I would say pretty no do
you think people are just lazy like I
won't [ __ ] walk am I gonna scooter
and then you give them the benefit of
the doubt like you would never imagine
that just well I didn't buy it so ya
know there's no rules what's the problem
but we would you ever in your life
imagine someone on a scooter was just a
lazy
that's insane mm-hmm that is just insane
but I'm afraid we might be having that
like like and I think they start to play
it off as it's embarrassing so they
start to play off like they have a
disability or something because it's
unimaginable that you would just do that
because you're lazy so then all the
sudden they start acting like there's
something wrong with them but they're
just [ __ ] lazy I can't you know
I don't know I didn't need to sound I
don't need to hear this guy's white
noise yeah she's totally [ __ ] fine
and she doesn't seem very phase that she
just literally drove through a glass
window either you know and she pieces
out yeah she's like alright well it's
another day she's like alright well is
there scooter insurance you could do you
think those people aren't sharable
they're sure to be like $10,000 a day
those people are walking liability
commuting liabilities
can you imagine insuring one of these
psychos oh this one's just great this
one is just iconic it's just called
backup Terry
I know if you watch this one no okay
good so a dude in a wheelchair letting a
firework hold her hand see go he's
lighting a really big firework sukar
okay
so they're like other cars are coming
but that's life
all right so he's lighting it and I'm
just gonna tell you what's happening for
those who are listening his wheelchair
stops man something about like people
from the hood freaking out is the
funniest thing ever I got it it reminds
me of that one went to talk with the
ball yeah I gotta play that outdoors I
gotta find this other one cuz yeah he's
good that's so funny black lady with a
dog [ __ ] Beach dude this video I mean
this is this is I swear to God the
funniest [ __ ] thing I have dude I'm
not gonna say [ __ ] let's watch this one
yeah this is the original [ __ ] box her
training directed by a proud owner mmm
how exciting he minds so good I wanna
show you something get that ball over
here about come on let's get you let's
get your ball and play with it then what
I want y'all to sing that you want oh
come on bring it out alright you see you
work anyway over this way are gonna
bring it on back don't show them how
good you do now I want you to show them
how good you know me come on I'm waiting
on you to throw your ball back to you
boy you just study right now come on he
got to do a little meditation you know
how dogs the years and all they have to
thank a little bit
ponder the whole situation it's so good
the dog shits in the ocean the ball gets
in the dog lays in the ship it's like
how could that happen actually no fine
I always wondered if it was like a clip
that the dude did voiceover - yeah
cousin so funny do you guys think that's
a genuine mom it's hard to tell yeah I
had the same thought that this might
just be over light but because if
somebody did that overlay I would want
to take credit for that because that's a
stroke of comedic turns oh my god it's
like it gets better like the guy's
already funny and then the dog shits in
the ocean I'm lays in it [ __ ] oh and
then this is another class just while
we're here
we're going out YouTube YouTube autoplay
get out of my life you know I'm saying
and you're gonna play me some [ __ ]
that's like you get media monetize
you're like oh did you want to watch
little girls in bikinis autoplay no I
don't even find the button where's the
button you two why you play me like this
dude would you like to watch would you
like to watch bikini watching naked
vagina next autoplay I'm out of this I
gotta get this Jesus Christ
do we want to all these oh I did haven't
watched that clip in so long oh man so
here's the one where people break their
hip visit [ __ ] so sweet so in
Netherlands
I love the Dutch man these guys are on
another level someone did a little Mario
Kart at it but basically they have old
people on scooters doing a [ __ ] race
bro like the Dutch know what's up they
already know what's up and they actually
had to tone back the event here I have
some right up here here's an article
that ela was translated and was cracking
up as if we laughing at and I'm a
translator here for you before I play
the video because it's very short first
of all you should play it for us so look
at the clip they use some old fat lady
looking down it says mobility scooter
adjusted next year due to broken hip
participant so here it is y'all ready
buckle up
I kind of like it you know I'm a Mario
Kart it is so much like Mario Kart the
similarity is insane dude that was such
a hard spill this way eat [ __ ] [ __ ]
and runs over a do yep I wish I had more
footage but that was all we could find
so shout out to the Dutch who know what
the hell they're doing last night when I
was watching all of these I could not
stop laughing and then I wonder now if
it's not as funny just because you
watched it already i watch it already or
is it not that funny dude how dare you
question that although I don't hear them
laughing him back which makes me wonder
I'm laughing okay good okay but I've
seen them all - so good I feel like if
one watch this at midnight like it's way
more funny that's true we work we gotta
we gotta do the podcast I mean that's
hard to Teeter on the edge because on
one hand you want to be surprised
I know but on the other hand you don't
want stinkers I need to know what we're
talking about through him you know you
need to curate it for the audience right
yeah but I like last night when I after
I watched this video and then I opened
that article - you're crying saying that
picture well to be honest with you guys
it was at like - I think that was even
probably 2 a.m. and then after that just
to put you in the time frame of our life
right now sleep has lost all meaning we
watched 2 hours of bachelor in paradise
last night at 2:00 a.m. he was like we
should go to bed I'm like dude what is
sleep even mean anymore
I'm on Ashley paradise I've been waiting
all [ __ ] day for this and yeah it's
worth this event
oh so we have the ultimate scooter clip
we'll do that after the break but
essentially this lady gets on the
freeway bro
like some like some like Louisiana look
in New Orleans looking like Mardi Gras
scooter classic dude so epic so this
this you don't go you definitely don't
want to miss where this goes
high-speed chase so we will be right
back after this quick commercial break
you know describe your look in one word
is it casual sophisticated playful fire
fire that wasn't an option but I like it
however you dress stitch fix has the
expert personal stylist that can help
you look your best that includes fire
okay
personal style is like a fingerprint
everyone's got their own whatever your
style the expert style says citrus are
ready to help you express yourself I
don't have a style I refute that I think
if you're like me most guys are like
just put clothes on me and make me
presentable and go out into the world
and that's the beauty of what stitch fix
does it prevents you from having to go
out in the world and it prevents you
from having to interact with other human
beings which is what and for me is the
number one priority at all my world I
was gonna make a reservation at a
restaurant yesterday I was like I'm
gonna call him I have to call them
tomorrow what a nightmare and then I
said no I'm gonna go online and make a
reservation I bet I can and I was right
that's what's district is for clothes
it's the restaurant reservation online
but for clothes does that make sense you
took a moment thinking okay but you're
there so stitch fix understands that
they're gonna give you a personal
stylist they're gonna set you up you're
gonna take a questionnaire you're gonna
tell them what's your style what's your
budget what you like and they're gonna
send you a box of clothing that is hip
stylish beautiful you're gonna look
great but here's where it gets even
better you try it on at home if you
don't like it you send it back you get a
roll full refund guys you're basically
switched out the dressing room for your
own home okay give me a break here
stitch fix calm slash h3 there's no
commitment required you only pay for
what you keep shipping
exchanges and returns are always free
plus the $20 styling fee is
automatically applied towards anything
you keep from your box Wow you never
have to think about looking good ever
again with stitch fix so get started
today at stitch fix calm /ht and you'll
get an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box that's stitch fix
dot-com / h3 stitch fix cob / h3
nobody and I mean nobody has got time
for the post-office you're busy we're
all busy who's got time for traffic
parking luggage to go and mail a package
it's a hassle and I'll tell you what
it's ancient technology you're gonna
trip over dinosaur bones on your way to
the post office it's out of control
that's why you need to go to stamps.com
it's the most popular time-saving tool
for small businesses and guess what it's
the future let's go to the Internet and
do it right
stamps I'll come he eliminates trips to
the post office and saves you money with
discounts that you couldn't even get at
the post office
stamps comm brings you all the amazing
services of the United States Post
Office write to your computer
we got simply use your computer to print
all US postage 24/7 for any letter any
package any class of mail anywhere
you'll want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to the mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it's really that
simple
with stamps.com you get five cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off Priority Mail so let me get this
straight it's cheaper and more
convenient sign me up
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of it of those expensive postage
meters Sam calm is a no-brainer saves
you time and money is a no wonder that's
700 thousand small businesses already
use stamps comp and check this out right
now our listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and you look ahead with the
digital skill and this is without any
long-term commitment that's a nice
looking skill dang look at that skill oh
snap look at that scale just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in h3
that stamps comm enter h3
ela did you know that 66% of men lose
their hair by age 35 I mean that is
outrageous that is unbelievable we have
to keep these men's beautiful heads of
hair where they belong on their heads
and not in the drain I think it's
outrageous that men turned to weird
solutions or do nothing at all when they
can turn to medicine and science because
guys let's face it a chia pet in full
bloom is so much better than a fresh
chia pet do you know what I'm saying you
have no idea you know everyone at home
does because we've got four hems kaam a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men it's an American
thing the chia pet okay you know it's
like an animal where the sprouts grow
out is it in my civics test it's it is
your servant this is your civic step
surprise thanks to science baldness can
be optional hems connects you with real
doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat your hair loss we got well known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your
beautiful luscious hair this is not any
BS this is prescription solutions backed
by science prescribed by real doctors
there's no waiting room no awkward and
person doctor visits you're gonna save
hours hours by going to four hems com so
easy answer a few quick questions
doctors will review and prescribe you
stop worrying about sun block on that
spalled spot of thinning hair and do
something to help the dang hair come
back help promote the hair growth
products are shipped directly to your
door right now
order now our listeners will get a trial
month of hems for just five dollars
today right freaking now while supplies
last so you better hurry
see website for full details and safety
information this would cost hundreds if
you went to a doctor or a pharmacy but
if you go to four hems dot-com / h3
that's fo r hims calm / h3 four humps
four hems com such a tree is gonna cost
you just five bucks for a one-month
drought
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what a treat I'm back from the break Wow
we have to acknowledge as we've talked
about it on this show many times little
nas ex who held the title of
longest-running number one on Billboard
was dethroned this week finally by Billy
Eilish and Ian put together this great
great little edit to commemorate the
occasion so I told a and I said you have
to add it edited by Ian but he didn't
want to factor Ian didn't even want to
play it but I came in I said no ah we're
gonna do this we're gonna play this this
is important to commit to met you know
to commemorate the occasion and I will
take credit there was a moment where the
Hat bounced on the ground that I thought
was a pretty flavorful but other than
that that was all in so anyone who's
like whoa that bouncing effect was crazy
that was me
the rest was Ian so we all appreciate
that right Ian nice teamwork it was a
real master class were you impressed by
my editing be honest I was like you came
in slick you fixed it real quick are you
just giving me lip service are you
serious I'm being serious thank you well
I am I've been editing up I mean I'm an
editor I always say I'm an editor first
and you don't get a how to bounce like
that without years of experience but I
will say to your credit in your really
good editor - yeah you butch it up
faster for your good man thank you
appreciate it
yeah yeah so Cheers
now back to scooter madness mm-hmm the
ultimate clip this really is if we can
find anything to top this then I'm gonna
be impressed but look at this situation
here this is a large woman she's got a
white wicker hat on I mean she looks
like a southern gal she's an oxygen tank
- that's pretty oh wow Vic forgot an
oxygen tank rigged forgotten oz for her
scooter it's like
hydro booths for whatever yeah durable
she's a large lady and she's really
squeezed in there man I mean she's kind
of spilling out the sides got a basket
but she's looked like she dolled up for
church or something right so um I don't
know but here we go
so she's in the middle of street and
then some kind Souls like damn this
lady's in danger I better escort her but
the lady on the scooter don't want to
have none of that she trying to lose it
to her she does want to be tailed trying
to lose the tail so what ensues is true
madness and for all your viewing
pleasure
she got a turn signal on this
why are you okay
[Music]
this woman doesn't even want that so
literally in the left land traffic is
building up behind a yeah so let me skip
ahead there's like big rigs going by her
like you know 16 wheeler so I mean just
skip ahead a little bit to worse
something it's a long clip it's like 12
yeah 11 minutes yeah and so let me just
go so accident she needs some help or
did she know where she was going I'm
we'll just let me know if you your
signal let me know we gonna signal I'm
still behind you Marvel I don't know
where but I'm helping her because they
are look at her she's going around the
traffic bro into an English balls deep
into a red light busy intersection fun
this is making a left turn on the red
lights but she did it
like frogger bro
she's Frogger again not a sweet little
lady charging it through the so what
what's happen is Isaac open a new window
so what's happening now is that she got
on the [ __ ] freeway they can't hear
you so she's trying to catch up now here
we go she's getting does she think she's
in a car I mean she's driving like I
don't know you got flowers where's she
going y'all I swear I don't put on her
her either I know I didn't notice that
the first time this woman is the same
yeah she really
so then when she called the police the
police show up and this is when [ __ ]
really gets out of hand she gets shot
dead it's crazy just I'm kidding
the police just show up and shoot her
it's totally uncalled for they just show
up in pepper spray in the face I wasn't
even thinking about that so they set up
a roadblock and I feel it
but nothing stuff in the scooter later
can gone wherever she's gone communing
beliefs are gonna stop her
think again
some was driving blinking around the
left everyone stop so now the police is
approaching her on foot and she hits it
hard she she she's the [ __ ] out right
around him she's all about hey she's
going fast the cop and now he's on foot
running she got too serious
she had the cut Wow the moment the cop
starts chasing a cartoon you had to get
where you're going man hmm
there you have it that one is gonna be
hard to talk no now going talking about
sorry yo am i hitting your night yard
near Jays um where's the feedback about
people were angry that that I was
sympathizing with mobility merry yeah
the I haven't seen it in our document
the messages yeah we're all link it to
you oh yeah so there was a reaction
strong reaction to me not completely
coming down on mobility marriage yeah
the terror of Santa Monica and I wanted
to read some of the feedback and
comments we got because apparently this
woman is worse than Adolf Hitler do we
have sound bytes of mobility marry
mobility marry I don't know okay so
here's some of the feedback we got from
mobility marry hi Dan I'm actually Santa
Monica where Mary is from and she has a
bit of reputation here kind of an urban
legend most people got angry with her
quickly because we all assumed she was
wandering around town trying to sue also
she's not a little old lady she's a
scooter bound because she's obese
I hope this helps we called it well
Hannah yeah kind of what we assumed but
do not sympathize with Mary she knows
what she's doing she can't be that
socially clueless to know how to record
for YouTube man these people really
there's real mobility Mary hate how can
you hate someone who's providing such
amazing content like what a treasure for
us to behold laugh my ass off she
definitely goes out of her way to create
problems in situations for videos yes
that's why you have to love and hate
right notice how all the bystanders were
on the girl were on the girl with dog
side everyone in the community knows
Mary and they know how Mary is what does
that mean that because she was trying to
get people to help her and everyone was
ignoring her oh yeah I know Ethan stop
sympathizing with this lunatic old lady
dude have some glass man did was that
not a joy and a pleasure how much fun do
we have enjoying that clip I'm supposed
to hate her I want her out in the world
doing her thing and recording it I want
more can't get enough I would pay her I
won't put her on salary to get her ass
out there I do find it crazy that she
managed to make a youtube channel that's
actually a good point she can't be that
crazy she's managing yeah oh that nah
that woman in the scooter is crazy she's
looking for trouble okay man she didn't
kill anyone
I've I've encountered Mary three times
well she even passed me in one of her
videos while costing someone else she's
a menace I've never once heard a
verified account of her being attacked
by a dog the most she ever gets is a dog
touching her scooter she's a horrible
woman I understand she coolly has issues
but she makes life immensely worse for
the people in her neighborhood come on
that's so epic that you've got this
menace in your society some fat lady on
a scooter that's the best thing I ever
heard why is Ethan defending this lady I
swear he's probably his grandma or
something
I wish my grandma's dead dude so how
[ __ ] dare you
I only wish that my grandma could be on
a scooter harassing people right sure
straight-up I can't believe you are
siding with her did this person super
upset when you start with straight-up
you hold on cuz this she's the one
putting herself in danger and being
annoying it's clear people know her and
hate her she literally had so much room
on that last clip and she just purposely
made a scene she acts like people need
to make a fifty foot wide [ __ ] bath
just so she can get through absolutely
horrible person I bet she ain't old
either she just fat and can't walk which
is another reason I don't feel bad also
she exterminated six million Jews it's a
little over the top that level of hate a
little bit I can't believe I strayed
like her mobility married literally
killed 20 million Russians in World War
two she genocided the Native Americans
I love mobility marry no amount of
feedback or hate or kickback will ever
change me and I'm willing to put her on
payroll right now I don't know how
tech-savvy she is but I swear to God
marry you contact us podcast is racial
productions.com I will put you on
payroll to go record videos of you
zipping around Santa Monica I will I'll
give you health insurance I'll do an
album and you know healthy water first
scooter bound obese lady I'm telling you
I'll do it for you I'm telling you you I
could even just make a pod a live show I
would be rich just put a live feed on
our hundred mobility scooter I'll get
her a quicker one two that can do more
damage that'd be crazy liability did to
be sued into the ground
but I'm willing to do it I'm going to
lose everything I have interesting to
get more fresh mobility motor
going on that we were talking about
buying our own scooter yeah and Dan and
the family back here at h3 nation have
put together some potentials so we will
review them and I think we have to make
a decision because we are definitely
buying a scooter this is not go we are
buying a scooter so let's say is in
order to decide which one so this was on
the subreddit actually like this one
there's one driver seat and two it's
almost like a train car alright it's
like a little table and then like wine
you know so this thing unfortunately I
don't know where they bought or they got
it custom-made lean well it's called the
limo
Nemo well how do you say that Lee
mobilizer yeah I don't think it's like a
limo mobilizer Oh limo ok mobilizer
there you go no of Andy cat people you
could also you know what to another name
for an immobilizer a car anyway so
that's a no and I we came to buy it I
don't know where to buy that so here's
one of Tucson wow this is a British
company has accomplished the Guinness
record their words longest mobility
scooter what we just looked at I think
so what's the cost but I'm telling you
the prices on these things are really
reasonable like look at this two seater
that's what I'm talking about $3,000 for
I mean that's a slick thing either look
at that cool Vespa front end so my
question is this one - cool
50 miles per hour probably it's too cool
dude it will hold passengers up to 600
pounds I love that 200 - wait - 600
pound dude that's like the fattest
personal I like 600 pounds is like I
think the fattest person that ever lived
that's gotta be total right the 600 its
to 300 passengers up - yeah right - 300
years is pretty big so pretty
can you met sick when you're 600 pounds
they need to like crane your ass
a prayer out of bed I'm not kidding like
here let me show you what a 600-pound
person looks like in case you are not
appreciating how much weight that is so
but in the meantime I feel like this one
almost looks too cool right I yes I
agree I'm trying to find a photo that I
can show my god this [ __ ] is crazy but
here these people are apparently 600
pounds of pop mmm yeah nice
so imagine scooters are gonna hold two
of those that's Oh Mike hit me up on
support fastest two-person mobility
scooters they see you know it holds 600
pounds and can be an extra $100 off the
scooter today what it what hi Mike can
one 600-pound person fit on this scooter
let's see let's look let's leave this
open and let's see if Mike does get back
Mike was pretty responsive yesterday
when I was doing my oh I don't know it
might have not been Mike but on this
site thing okay okay well we'll see
about that
yeah next step will give Mike a chance
to respond and we've got top mobility
let's see
Oh what that looks like the Batmobile
like that purple is crazy it's like a
motorcycle 3000 oh it's cheap 1000 yeah
why Oregon while these websites look
like scams you know like I don't know
man because it's like they care to old
people and old people get scammed so
easily I don't know what watch the scam
I don't think it's a scam but I don't
think it's a scam it's kind of like FUBU
for us by us old people shopping at old
people like if you even go to this
website you can't look all hip and like
oh it's a new dam these guys have the
same [ __ ] all right leave me alone
come on mom with my
so okay I mean I do look at the customer
support one some all dude like are you
kidding me
but the headset on come on this last leg
I love the color selection yeah it's
pretty badass but like they're all cool
I don't really hot colors yeah like hot
pink hot purple hot green oyster target
audience other than ice like cuz I don't
see an old person buying that I wanna
have fun you wanna cruise in style how
fast is this one this one is 18 miles
per hour
whoa 45 mile drive range are you freakin
kidding me
do it I can like charge to the airport
and that thing down the 405 yeah all
right
Oh Mike said yes you can I'm I can't
what about what about to six hundred
pound people we can get some clarity on
this this is good good that's crazy so I
would have to probably remove the center
divider if your one 600-pound right here
he's typing let's let's await his
response here this is exciting this is a
h3 podcast live exciting interaction
with Mike yeah you give me a good
thoughtful answer the weight capacity in
total is 600-pound okay well garbage
what about one person that weighs 400
and one person that weighs 205 come on
door goes here you know I mean I love
that all these web sites have an old
person is the support picture yes that
would work oh so Mike's I'm very good at
math so wait so you're saying I can go
five pounds over capacity
interesting oh wow look at this one yeah
looking 400 and it's got like over now
this I'm already liking a lot more this
is like get the [ __ ] out of my way it's
more this you can you can hate people
and you're gonna stay fine right they're
just gonna wipe off the shield yeah like
this one I need speed though 50 miles
per hour 40 miles drive range that's
crazy 500 pounds of raw hardcore driving
mobility yes there you see these
[ __ ] think they're in cars turn
that's what I'm looking for
oh [ __ ] you see Mary's new scooter what
are you so humiliated about there it's
like a is it a status symbol and these
like retirement communities might be
right about that yeah it's old I got the
call Brad G look what my son bought me
and you got the e there's some broke-ass
old person was like a beat-up barely
functioning one no thought people judge
them you seen that Cobra yeah yeah check
over DT is the cool guy on Mike says yes
on a large capacity my model a few
pounds over will not harm the machine
hell yeah so what a so so how much over
can I go
I don't think it's that interesting
there how many more pounds you could go
so if I weigh so if I weigh 650 is that
okay you don't like this conversation
I'm trying to get to the bottom of this
you look I think you're missing out cuz
you should keep checking out the links
go the next one oh wow that looks scary
that looks menacing good what that looks
menacing oh lucky yes it's listed at
nine thousand but it's only on today on
this scam website four thousand mm-hmm
that thing looks really cool
wait 10 miles per hour what the [ __ ] you
took what kind of scam were they running
oh really I so slow you know why you get
this so slow is because you're like dude
I don't trust my grandma with 50 miles
per hour yeah they they all do actually
have limiters for exactly that reason so
you can set them up and restrict them to
like but I'm surprised that this one is
slower it's more expensive it's slower
and has a lower range it even has a coal
you know what it is guys hmm
actually no I'm wrong it's 50 pounds
less hmm okay no they're just lacking on
the code actually fragment next one is
very classy so mike says just to follow
up I'm gonna end it here there's no
specific amount I'd say six 25 or so is
gonna be on the safe side thanks Mike
okay thanks Mike you've been very
helpful
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm very large now close the window
quick I would love to take you on a
scooter ride and it's beautiful
well you accompany a come come accompany
me
there will not be much room so I that
mega do to help your weight is not very
high can we move on
under under 100 no I like the scooter
combo not good I don't know how much of
a good show it is for people to listen
to type all right where are we what's
new it's getting about it so the next
one I like a lot and the next next one I
like a lot which we on the Maverick yes
oh this is Logan paws scooter and
something's actually calling them retro
girl looks like a chopper yep the front
is like a chopper oh wait sorry we know
we were under one above it we haven't we
go back to that one but this one again
9.5 miles per hour
okay I'm gonna hurt people no you know I
mean that's my prime objective they're
not we don't look at the Cobra GT yeah
we looked at the heavy-duty off-road
tires oh sure this one's 4,000 oh I
really like the look where we were going
off-roading huh go hiking on a scooter
hello did this bat nine point three
miles per hour top speed
yeah but the joke is probably really
good it's for climbing at 500 pounds
what the [ __ ] man I feel like the same
person owns all these ones okay
cuz they all wear the spam look at
here's another old guy yeah I mean any
time this is all once can't
I know marketing I know I know this
world it's the same dude who owns all
these websites he imports these scooters
probably from China and he just slings
him to every single person and he gets a
little Commission yeah I guarantee
that's what's happening Mike says like
it's typing a response so it won't port
back on that gila maverick we don't like
the Maverick no the dual sitter so far
I'm not really a super magnet oh my
goodness look at this like a tractor now
these people are not even the
sable these are like filthy looking
people yeah what but check out the sit
it can Oh it swivels wait how do you
drive how are they driving if the seat
swivels to the side it doesn't matter
anyway you mean you be in the seat
driving and then you'd have to be like
this pretty much how they drive anyway
so dude why are you so you can't surely
it doesn't swivel why you drive right no
really I I was assuming it would but how
can you also why are these people so
young and happy then max speed 10 miles
per hour I think my my requirement is
testimonials on the bottom Mike said
sorry I'm over 100 how much do you weigh
and I'm gonna ask Mike how much do you
weigh scroll down to the bottom yeah
more yeah yeah look at this old people a
big thank you to all you guys that
progress mobility my scooter arrived in
only three days and I absolutely love it
your service from start to finish has
been excellent the other day I fell off
the side of the curb and broke my hip it
wasn't the scooters fault but thank you
Mike said it's how much do you weigh
Mike said enough so it's a real person
do you drive one of these scooters Mike
you know I think this must be the actual
owner yeah because it goes to his phone
I think it's one guy
I think so too it's one guy who owns all
these sites there's not that much track
I've heard about this support chat it's
just it just pops up on your phone well
also the way he's interacting with me is
like he's like doing something else he's
like watching sports or something that
Mike d/dr on these scooters he says I do
not
oh why were you listening to him my I'm
I'm afraid you've lost all credibility
I've lost all respect wait
like I'm afraid you've lost all
credibility
this guy's like all right you've really
entertained me I appreciate that what
else we got so that Gatsby that sounds
crazy the Gatsby bro it's like a look
it's like a cream yeah oh my god Dean
powered Otto locomotive train it's
called the Gatsby the old gasps Wow
you know there's book The Great Gatsby
yeah he's the old and dangerous Gatsby
this is lit okay to prove my point this
is the same picture this is the same old
dude who's doing top mobility unless
we've been to the psychic analogy which
is possible of this color because you
can't move yourself technology in the
movies you're badass whoa you can lean
it back
don't say it three times give me Montez
lean back
that's two off your green so it's pretty
fordable 3,500
well let's oh wow let's see how fast
does it go
I mean that's really after that is the
big question looks their storage in the
front for the engineer would be all
right 10 miles per hour get the [ __ ] in
there are all 10 miles no there were
some 15 ones in the beginning oh yeah
yeah last week I remember I need one
that goes fast the fast ones all look
cool though hold on Mike said okay yeah
I said Mike if I'm afraid you've lost
all credibility he said okay maybe he's
not going there now okay Wow
so yeah Ethan follow up and okay the
first one goes up to 15 miles per hour
but it it just looks like a scooter like
a lame right they get rid of the if
speeds the priority there the there's
one more yeah on the way thousand yeah
it's
you're gonna pay for that speed whoa
what is this yeah yo this is like such a
flexible oh my god it looks like a
snowmobile this [ __ ] goes 20
miles an hour
whoa this guy is flexing hard at the old
photo yeah you know all those guys hate
him that guy guess all the old [ __ ]
he's got a he's got a toe too many
options then okay well this is the one I
mean but at 20 miles per hour it's in
our budget eight thousand dollars for a
gag for stupid guy the problem with this
one Dan is that it's almost not even a
mobility scooter it's like a
four-wheeler TV I think I read down
below that um it's street-legal
because of how they write it on streets
up 35 mile per hour
wait wait it doesn't dollars you can buy
a car you could buy like a pretty decent
car at 8,000 wait hold on what's what's
the mileage on this baby it's the same
old guy okay it's the same way
specifications let's get to the bottom
is 50 miles per charge 20 miles per hour
bro they a climbing power 30% incline
what is that Oh like a third percent
angle you can hit it no I think I think
you pins before the engine ground
clearance
weight capacity bro it could be a
hamster turning radius it can hold this
in 726 pounds dude oh wow that is like
dude you could drive yourself told you
man this is like the mack daddy this is
the this is the big boys good home
control this program big yeah it's such
it's I would just buy a car but it's
kind of dope you could I mean it's so
big you're just on a TV disguised as a
mobility scooter right yeah yeah pretty
much
you need a license for that
okay well look guys I know what we're
getting out of control I think what we
really need is something classic
something iconic I can we named a lot
like it's just we kind of need like
seven over them
yeah but I've been Evo whose words that
money coming from you know like um seven
car garage we need a so yeah need a
sponsorship yes Stan now there there is
a video of the Gatsby and it it might it
might sell you on it that one's pretty
epic super cool um oh yeah let's watch
it I see here now I watch this last
night you know you did a title of the
video caught my eye because it's not all
the video read it for the six four seven
eight yep for Biden please go to two
zero six three seven eighty three calm
yeah the title of it is just two oh six
four seven eight so there you have it
so in the in the back half of this video
there's a demo and it's you know you can
see how cool you look it's just
copyrighted music I'm pretty sure it's
uh
royalty-free because I've heard it on a
million YouTube videos I mean it's funny
how when you're when you get all of you
becomes almost like a kid right just
looks like good toy for a kid this one's
free dough but Lord there you go your
feet in an elevator
yeah that other one would it do you
think this one this one's almost too
cool though Dan no but like it's not
intimidating I want one that says do you
think I think that's good goes one cool
[ __ ] I'm sorry it's too good
Gatsby The Great Gatsby we should do a
vote well yeah we got a narrow it down
though the Gatsby's they're like a
Twitter pool yeah hate Twitter will Ian
what would you vote I'm going with the
you did the Gatsby or the two-seater the
one that swivels
do we have any more questions for Mike
before we close this you said okay all
right Mike well can you ask him about
the swivel one is it the same website we
saw one on another website Oh
considering the business of mobility
tell me and my wife she liked to be able
to see our surroundings look around
always good I kind of like this this the
classic though because you know mobility
marry when you see this classic scooter
coming I hate your JS again that's when
you know you're in trouble this one well
this one's not classic this one's out of
[ __ ] game I'll tell you which one is
classic mmm
recreational scooter oh this one's
pretty classic no this one's not quite
this one's psycho - yeah in the Gatsby
everyone's gonna vote for the Gatsby
well you guys have mentioned wanting to
potentially trick this thing out I feel
like the Gatsby has a lot of sorry it's
already tricked yeah I guess that's true
it's already tricked yeah you got to
find some normal ones cuz you got all
the crazy-ass ones there are some
normies in there I mean the UW 36 right
any W 30 times
oh that's the colored one I mean other
than the color that's pretty special but
yeah I guess so what do you love yeah
yeah
what oh come on our chairs yeah
[Laughter]
wait I want to see him oh [ __ ] nice
no wine
look how why that baby is hold on I want
to find it why just one I guess this one
let's get more info
yo that one's pricey five thousand look
at the size of that thing
well what does its do stand your ass up
oh it does it yeah
jazzy elite it's called jazzy elite I
don't know if I'd call that jazz you
might do it
jazzy elite HD heavy duty power chair HD
see what the weight capacity is and he
liked what I was saying before just
because you fell down an elevator shaft
oh my God look at this pop-up I got oh
oh they're pushing that 70% off let me
enter my you're emailed in oh man sir
the podcast one if you get a crazy
coupon code for the Gatsby then we'll
buy it yeah okay get my offers they're
on it I just sent that email that email
just will be uncheck about forever now
hmm that email dress just got sold to a
thousand Chinese spammers they also have
a bunch of accessories like a cup holder
I'm gonna scooter no just go to
accessories where's Mike yes
you got the bin you got what the [ __ ]
you know someone's gonna be driving
around with that thing on
take a weather protector why do you have
your scooter outside I guess good no mmm
where would you put it yeah well I think
we've I think it's the Gatsby
unfortunately I don't know if I like the
Gatsby but well if that's what I'm
talking about I think you gotta get I
think you gotta get four wheel
I don't like a bit three like this looks
pretty powerful for will full-sized
mobility scooter oh that's a performance
scooter that's all--that's they do
tricks and [ __ ] okay show me the speed
7.5 get the [ __ ] out of here 11 that's
pretty good that's the thing you kept
emphasizing speeds well what am I trying
to get somewhere man so I'm saying die
before you get to your destination for 7
8 5 20 mother [ __ ] I like this one mega
mega neighborhood electric vehicle with
solid roof there's [ __ ] ten
thousand dollars you could buy it almost
a new car a new car for that price get
out of here
7.5 what is this look at this
do you see this is called ten baskets on
it alright this is out of control this
is what I want do you see this is a
normal scooter yeah five miles per hour
that is where we started originally why
is it so slow
dan I want one that looks oh whoa all
right this is it
are you seeing this it's a little
self-contained I've never seen anything
like that in my life this would talk
about turning heads look at this to the
picture somewhere anyone owns this I
don't think anyone's ever but there's
one review five stars well let's see
what they said I love the scooter I now
can get out in any way there and the
tires go right through the snow it's
like having a small electric car with
all the features of a car
did this work so this person gave it a
five on appearance a four for quality
and price a one-star for portability oof
yeah maneuverability a three you could
hit those turns a little harder their
ability a for taking some heat all right
I think we've been on this too long yeah
where's Mike does Mike have anything
else to say I'm over Mike I think we're
both over each other but in short I want
something like this dan I'm just gonna
buy it this one goes I think then miles
is fine ten is good I want ten I was
having trouble finding 10 this one is
seven and a half seven I'll take
something out oh look at the umbrella
oh yeah it's only $100,000 let's get the
[ __ ] okay on this [ __ ] to limo
in short we're gonna buy scooter I'm
curious what you guys think though like
a classic scooter a two-seater or the
Gatsby maybe like yeah and that'll be
the the pole all right fair enough okay
to theater win the swivel no not this
one no this one this was stupid you
can't swim over drive it I like this one
it's not stupid what if you're at a
parade wait I like this one okay wait
okay lo you're one behind I don't know
way yeah yeah how did they make it look
like it yeah each other this doesn't
it's just dangle it's kind of cool
so you can [ __ ] with people while I
Drive you can like throw kicks you can
put it over behind you all right well
let's see what the people think whatever
the people decide we are literally gonna
buy a scooter okay okay well we're
better in our 2002 talk about the
YouTube Seuss thing that's the main
story right so YouTube is okay you two
you know open a can of whoop-ass on
click farms these farms that are out
there Manuel claiming videos for even a
split second of using copyrighted [ __ ]
questionable tactics and YouTube is
striking back against copyright trolls
and the continuation of the story is
that YouTube is suing a particular
individual a copyright troll who use
DMCA strikes and tried to extort money
from youtubers now this is one of these
guys that goes around just making up
claims he goes he like it's crazy that
the system even allows that this is just
some dude who says hey I strike your
video there's no content in it that he
owns he's just a guy yeah and so this
guy was going around giving people
strikes and then saying send me a
hundred fifty bucks on PayPal or I'll
have your channel removed and he and he
could do that by giving someone three
yea strikes it's unbelievable it's this
antiquated DMCA law it's not really
YouTube's fault so they're going after
this guy YouTube is using the fraudulent
claim provision of the DMCA to sue Chris
Brady a man who allegedly used DMCA
two-strike to gaming channels Kenzo and
OB raids he also contacted the youtubers
directly and threatened to issue a third
strike if they did not pay him one
hundred and fifty dollars the issue came
to light in February when it was
reported by by The Verge it all kicked
off when Obie tweeted about it back in
January when it went viral I actually
like this sweet - I don't call it
because this stuff was happening all the
time but here's the message he was
sending people hi Obie we strikes you
our request is 150 PayPal or 75 Bitcoin
it's a good value you may send the money
via good services
you do not think we will cancel or hold
up our end of the deal once you receive
our payment we will cancel both strikes
on your channel again you are free to
charge back if we don't but assure you
we will well I like the guarantees she's
okay we'll provide a service here I mean
come on we're reputable is there not
honor do not trust me if you decide not
to pay us we will file a third strike
VIPRE MC ownership team won't be able to
help you but go ahead and try we'll give
you a very short amount of time to make
your decision if you have any questions
send us a quick message back crazy right
yep so the guy I think he just tweeted
that he's paying them and and and you
know that's not a terrible decision to
make
no actually that that second image was
they saw that he tweeted about it and
threatened him further said bad news
quality kind of thing hey we saw you
tweet about us not sure why you thought
that was a good idea or if you thought
you would remotely get any help but this
has violated any potential Geale enjoy
your third copyright strike and we'll be
making jam for your Twitter to get
suspended too well you know that's all
on this guy right there man what a piece
of [ __ ] holy crap and you know he's not
the only one you can anyone can do this
apparently I mean YouTube's getting
speiser about it now I think probably
can't be done now but back on the day it
could and YouTube remembers and this guy
think he got away with it but now
YouTube's coming back hard and if you
think when YouTube Google alphabet
lawyers when they open the gates on you
you are done this is a horde of lawyers
that I would I would rather I would
rather live in exile from this country
that I love that face a horde of Google
lawyers and telling you it's that crazy
YouTube investigate it and remove the
strikes on this channel but Brady
continued to issue fraudulent DMCA
at least four more times he allegedly
sent for copyright takedown doses to
YouTube between June 29th in July 3rd
stating that the youtuber excellence and
kids got to work on his name a little
bit ZyXEL looks in infringe on his
content and that so this is this part
absolutely blew my mind he then went on
to use the personal information of this
guy acquired via the DMCA takedown to
swat him so for those of you that don't
know the DMCA process requires that you
put in your address and phone number
when you either file or counter the
dispute and I quickly realized a my
YouTube career early on how terrifying
that was because I first when I first
was met with that forum I was like oh
this must just be for YouTube's internal
use yeah right like I was like there's
no way you're kind of beefing with
someone exactly why would I send that
person my information they do not make
it at all clear at all
I'm like okay well sending this info to
this person who strike my video would be
unimaginably insane so I'm sure it's
just for their internal use so the
lawsuit or something legal happens they
know what happened nope
they send it directly to the other
person and so you'd they say put in your
your address put in your telephone
number put in your email and when you're
you know young and impressionable and
these forms are really scary you and I
did this too in the beginning I would
put in that information like my exact
information my real [ __ ] and when I
found out it went to the other person I
was actually terrified I was scared so
what I started doing was putting a
pillbox and my accountants phone number
mm-hmm the location of our business
you know but it's it's it it's
terrifying and and and this worst fear
came true for this poor guy like I used
the info to SWAT him that is beyond
insane so I wonder if they have proof
for everything I mean and then I wonder
how old is he
because that's a serious offense right
just watch someone yeah that's
definitely illegal but I wonder if
there's a statute of limitation because
there's stuff all happened a long time
ago hmm no not that long ago just a few
months ago no I'm pretty sure
wait the lawsuit was filed or this all
happened the lawsuit was filed - hold on
I mean it was just filed but um let me
see when the street was made this tweet
was made it was like February of this
year
oh yeah February this year yeah and the
was this was in yeah well he probably
will be okay
I doubt the police were even aware like
YouTube is the one bringing all of this
information forward yeah so they filed a
complaint against this guy and he is
going down hard and I love it I mean
this guy is rock bottom scum yeah so I
think swatting someone should be
attempted murder
I think well go to jail it's so
dangerous they show up at your door with
guns people have died yeah and the guy
went to jail for murder right so good
point it stands to think that it's the
one you should be charged with attempted
murder yeah there should be no tolerance
for that I agree and then also be
charged for they're also wasting
everyone's time to shop with helicopters
and a whole team and prison walking the
streets it's crazy
prison for ten years at least for that
bye bye neck try again in ten try again
in a decade [ __ ] so stupidest thing to
do I mean I can't even imagine being in
the headspace of someone to actually
swap
it's beyond and saying
YouTube personally dissed him in the
complaint they say Brady's extortionate
and harassing activities described here
maybe in at least part motivated by his
failings as a minecraft youtuber the
lawsuit reads how epic is that I love
that a previous precedent over
fraudulent DMCA takedowns awarded the
plaintiffs 25,000 per single fraudulent
claim the suit alleges Chris Brady
issued at least eight so it could be on
the hook for at least two hundred
thousand dollars of penalties I don't
think those hundred fifty dollar charges
are gonna stack up to something tells me
that didn't pay off for you so YouTube
is stepping it up in a huge huge way and
I'm so happy to see that because these
this is like they're going after the
perfect guy too because this is rock
bottom rock bottom scum er II I think
it's so great they're that they're doing
something and it's really feels like
they're making a change fine really
yeah they're actually doing stuff no
it's fantastic I mean imagine anyone out
there who's doing who's doing activity
like this all the sudden is like Oh a
billion dollars worth of lawyers was
just unleashed to ruin this guy's life
maybe I should rethink this because up
until this point up until this lawsuit
was filed there was no accountability
there was no consequence to many of this
problem is that it is that serious but
if you're just a kid you you don't
understand maybe the how serious these
things are it's hard to feel the
consequence like this is a cyber crimes
this is kind of a new frontier yeah it's
hard to track it's hard to understand it
so but we're getting better at it and
YouTube isn't gonna be coming to you
buddy
all these kids swatting to they think
that like they do it and honestly the
FBI can find your ass bro you know the
guys have got something and they
do you know the guy who got someone
killed with swatting the FBI found his
asked him like five [ __ ] days and
guess what he's in prison for jail so if
you think your cute ass is Anonymous for
Gail what'd I say
prison for jail yeah I'll get too
excited he's in prison yeah they locked
his ass away for murder so if you think
your cute ass calling on skype can SWAT
someone and not be found out not the
case you will go down so get your head
out of your ass and a wash your face
brush your [ __ ] teeth and build a
Minecraft house and living it I don't
know but I'm happy these people are
worse man I'm very happy so I applaud
YouTube I thank them for their efforts
and I wish them well I wish them
continued I'm with them on this war this
battle I'm taking down these motherf
Ricker's right right and finally
PewDiePie friend of the show friend of
ours king of YouTube's biggest dick in
the game totally unfair I don't
understand
PewDiePie he's handsome he's charismatic
he's good at making videos he's rich
I mean why is it that and it's still yet
everybody loves him it seems paradoxical
what's going on with this guy why is it
that the N cells are not wise the insult
army not after PewDiePie yet they love
him they all love him everybody loves
PewDiePie
what is happening everybody loves
PewDiePie including his now-wife Marzia
they've been Wed and holy matrimony and
we give here to honor him PewDiePie and
his wedding day ah beautiful what do you
think of the black suit I like it what I
love her dress
yes dress they got good taste I knew
they were gonna come out sharp the venue
looks really beautiful too every
blowing bubbles mm-hmm of course they're
all picturesque [ __ ] you know what I'm
happy for even [ __ ] you Felix right I
mean like everyone's got an m1 and be
like like [ __ ] you right you guys know
what I'm talking about
look at his hair he's got like perfect
hair like what the [ __ ] why did how can
you know I mean hopefully he's dick
small or something oh please got like a
300 you know like up hopefully his penis
looks like a pencil eraser anyway
they're beautiful they're happy I'm
happy for them and let me see the rock
oh that's a stone right there right
that's a fat diamond hmm I'm supposed to
be the one that looks of the ring well
I'm just you know nosy
well what do you think of the ring be
nice it's beautiful
oh these are little diamonds - whoa
that's a you'd rock dude yeah that looks
really beautiful look at this so
picturesque and beautiful doing like a
greenhouse or some [ __ ] yeah really nice
fairy tale how to be PewDiePie no I'm
very happy with my life I'm very
satisfied with every aspect love it I'm
just saying I'm sure there's a lot of
people to [ __ ] hate his guts but also
love them cuz everyone loves food bye
so congratulations to the newlyweds
there's some fun responses to his uh
ela say congratulations with the why are
you winking I was curious I thought it
was cute hmm cuz it cuz the wink implies
somehow that you're like almost you
don't mean it
you like congratulations but you did
mean it
Einstein instead I just thought was a
cute face Ethan okay
here I made a comment and our mochi
games are scray in fire lately
congratulations
wishing you both lifelong comfort and
joy and pooping with the door open
which I'm proud to say that we now mean
he would now enjoy that luxury together
I poop with the door open because you
are mid-conversation a lot of times you
know I really don't mind it as long as
I'm not liking yet don't watch me yeah
if I'm not in front of you
don't put up put a chair down and watch
me [ __ ]
you know I'm [ __ ] and I guess also
maybe I would have minded it when we
used to live in a tiny apartment I could
see that no escape from the smell and
the sound yeah so I could see that being
a problem but today yeah we just leave
the door open
well not every time but it's just not
I'm willing to do that with you that's
where we are which I wish them that
level of comfort in their lives as well
they may already have that comfort in
joy but in true
let's see lots of oh wow
that's an inappropriate when racists get
married come on dude why is that at the
top even like Twitter's like yeah let's
put that at the top shut up dude a lot
of that's what dude this is a conspiracy
theory it has 300 likes all these have
like tens of thousands mine has a lot of
comments maybe it said you know people
went crazy for that one by the way I
don't I mean who's this ethan klein with
55,000 likes whoa who's that guy bomb
athletes apparently who did I believe in
bomb tweets
holy [ __ ] let me check out his profile
it says let's see the replies that I'm
gonna get into it do you think Marc sees
a racist because she's a telling it in
you races mmm-hmm that's an interesting
argument okay Shane is happy Jack's film
is happy Jeff made some Minecraft edits
now that's a wedding venue well he
recreated every photo in Minecraft man
you gotta love it give it up for Jeff
Swiper people
keemstar put all this effort into a very
heartfelt message he couldn't even be
bothered to write out congratulations
he simply said congrats no punctuation
just congrats so thank you for the
thoughtful message to keemstar not
impressed I'm a youth football coach
Legend so wake me up when you have two
championship rings which are infinitely
more valuable than wedding rings it's
fair enough cinnamon toast can with the
Flex he was at the wedding thanks for
having it being at PewDiePie's wedding
is like the Last Supper
you know Cooper's is in the middle and
then they painted it like the closeness
is how important you are
so cinnamon toast was at the supper
table so congratulations to you and so
on and so forth
what is this congratulations this is
totally unrelated but toilet paper areum
I want to wipe your tears away oh I like
that that's cool oh it's not even
earrings just a clip that's awesome I
would buy that
anyway we wish you well baby bye and on
a serious note congratulations I I
really truly think that they have a
strong meaningful relationship they've
been together for so long you know and
it's pretty cool actually to see them
like I'm seeing them together for so
long I mean my god how long have they
been together like who knows probably
seven years yeah that's great I think
it's beautiful I think I love to see a
role model like Felix can show that a
happy fulfilling long-term relationship
as possible mm-hmm and that it could be
meaningful and sustainable mm-hmm
because I really do think that well you
know with you I have a love is they
really love you compared to when you see
someone
with a different girl every week which
is kind of the norm these days maybe I
don't know but him being like the number
biggest internet star handsome young man
he's settling down and well she's a
catch to listen yeah man you know Google
search says they've been together since
2011 so yeah it's like eight years yeah
I'd like it I think he's a I think he's
a good boy it's a good message yeah it
is I think he's a good role model in
that way
although the insoles would say it's just
his bone structure so depends how you
look and she's a gold digger yeah she's
so depends how you looking anyway
congratulations to pewdiepie we love you
we appreciate you wish you all the very
best in life and all the things to come
and Marzia as well mm-hmm I'm a fan of
Marcia she's a real sweet I mean she out
here apart in Seoul we have this story
about the huge Amazon fires but let's
talk about that on Friday shall we Dan
mm-hmm sounds good we've got the beach
buggy we've got the fan mail from the
salmon and next week we're gonna do
Arby's taste test advert verse reality
I'm looking farted that actually yes
very much because the truth is the fat
guy and me just wants to eat Arby's like
I secretly just want to eat fast food
not that secretly yeah it's not I
literally am so yeah the week after that
we're gonna be doing a chat box
reality verse how are you doing on your
diet
what would you say that ELA no I'm
kidding I'm down I'm still trending
downwards okay that's good I'm I talk
about I look I'm doing it on Noom no
I'll give updates on the next sponsor I
read ok I got a lot to report though
it's exciting ask me
okay you don't look excited why are you
doing this I can't believe you've done
this you should show off your necklace
before we go I don't know if you guys
can zoom can see but we could see it
pretty well like a blinged-out teddy
bear teddy bear it's pretty dope it's
[ __ ] sick don't get fooled it's not
actual
don't Romans I personally don't see the
value in real diamonds just as good
thing is if that was real diamonds it
would cost like two hundred thousand
dollars it would look exactly the same
and you would be paranoid and scared
shitless but damn we'll put a pole so
we'll decide which one to buy and maybe
next time we'll just have the scooter
right then well we're done I know she
turned it down
before we go can we see your shoes no
she called me fat so I'm denying her
shoe can I call you fat well I think
you're giving update on your diet I
wanted to follow up you live with me you
know my dad is not a stranger
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]